l'heure des vacances a sonné les beaux
jours sont arrivés et pour plusieurs la
kfw de c'est du passé votre mot c'est
fini ben jemâa encore dans les mains qui
le désinfectant surtout mai
hu a pour l'instant c'est du passé en ce
sens avant de croquer tension pourquoi
je changerais pour moi depuis le début
de la pandémie est en pleine septième
bague jamais les québécois ont autant
penser que la coved était derrière nous
c'est pas surprenant dans un contexte où
les mesures obligatoires ont été
enlevés selon un sondage de l'institut
national de santé publique du québec le
lavage des mains et la distanciation
physiques sont en chute libre les 60 ans
et plus demeurent les plus nombreux à
être prudents les 18 24 ans sont ceux
qui ont abandonné les mesures en plus
grand nombre
et pour ça une personne portel max forte
et je pense qu'on est rendu
ailleurs je peux avoir un spectacle mais
j'ai mis masques et puis soit faire
attention évidemment les personnes plus
âgées peuvent se sentir plus à risque si
elle attrape la colle vu donc une
tendance généralement à continuer de
suivre ces mesures l'eau alors que chez
les plus jeunes on dit jamais ou parfois
c'est sûr si une grande inquiétude
l'importance de masques n'est pas
souligné assir le docteur donald vinh
souligne que l'explosion des cas surtout
dans la région de la capitale-nationale
affecte tous les secteurs de la société
et de l'économie parce que le virus est
devenu plus bénin il arrêter ce qui si
on regarde l'impact sur notre système de
santé qui est en train encore une fois
de de faillir de colas et je pense qu'on
est en trop j'ai apporté mon arrivée je
les ponts mais des experts et des
médecins s'inquiètent déjà pour
l'automne sans mesures supplémentaires
comme le port du masque les éclosions
risque encore une fois de se multiplier
ici pierre alexandre bolduc radio canada
québec